今日はちょっとなんて言えばいいゲーム実況とはちょっと違う感じなんですけれども
えっと北どうぞ見てくださっている中学生の男の子からずっと言って欲しいゲームがあ
るっていうね
me
なんか僕僕が主人公みと読むらしいんですけど
rpg なんですけど
大丈夫かなぁセックスの中学校の男どこがわざわざグレイス人カードゲームをつくって
くれたということで今日はかな
どっち人かゲームはちょっとやってみようと思う
なんだ俺主人公受はいということで実際にやっていこうと思います
柔道を止めで3000ディ方向ということで
ん
おかしいだろもうちょっと大変だからちょっと悪意があるというか
まあいいんですけど
やっていきます
大
今はそう遠くない未来だろうか付き合うとミックに支配されたのだろうか
まあ頑張れば
何かので+稲荷とミックさんですか
パリーポッターと炎のタブレット
タブレット
社長トミックに大事な議論を取られおこなのです
そういう
理屈なわけです前かかり[ __ ]の係長っていうね男のば作ってくれたんだよ
ボルドさオーナー
すごいないでくださいはああーーーーっっっ
のデラックスやーはながらなぁ
うわぁ spunky
これが後輩ですね
コンビニ行ってくるって loop 俺は正木ろーっ
あん皆で行こう
なんならを動ける
なんなのこれこれがん
ここは奴らです
1泊12 g ですがお泊りになりますか
家
ここは教会ですん
復活するパターンかと
んをっ
4すげー
神た3冊を正木おまけ
パスでへ食べ
デラックスな扱いな
シャーペン度ダウンボールから装備があっ
続 gree
潜っている
まあさっきはん
ハーイ論とか
なってらつに限っちゃう武器持ってないですからね
ドレッドのメンバーは僕とは正キット deluxe らしいですね
大丈夫だこのゲームスライムジャンプ
thrive 笑ったかわかっ
ぬんだのこのゲーム
ちょっと外に行ってみます
おおーー
よくこんなの作ったねー
パソコンいじってる場合じゃない牛丼食べたいっ
なんだなこの寝る場合じゃないって言うと食べたい
何だろうか変だ何か
俺そんなゲイナーは牛丼好きですけれども
そんなにねぇあれだよ
好きってわけじゃないよ好きだけどそんな子人がいる
おらはな笑笑笑笑笑笑笑笑笑
いじめさんはじめ雪は何見てるんですよ
分かった
あ畑だからー大
ああああああ
はあああ
はい早くも人を殺めてしまうというこの退散水はまた人がいる
生きて帰った人間はこれだけか何の話ですか
どういうことを
何かある
おいだ疲れたもおだろい何
なんだろ
カオスだなぁ女の人がいるん
9あずとがバレたらトミック3
闘劇歳のて来ちゃらしいです
濃いなあ
もう何どう色々とすごいわ
とみっを
この先この先中京つけろ
もうここは地球じゃないって設定ですねを
はぁ1ゴールド
search 中に売れだなぁと者多いどういうことだ
本
ということを
ゲームオーバーまさか
はぁんっ
どうすりゃいいの
テメリザーブ
は
冒頭
ちょっともう1回やり直しますあそこで宝箱とっちゃの負けです
を最初でクラッシュも花ですね
入ったら戻れなくなるんでここはもうスルーします
セーブできるんですよ整備して
テストプレイしてるといっ
セーブしました
よし
大
音楽がいいですねー
魚犬いいねめっちゃいる
はぁっ何なぁ
大
痛い
えっ
そうなゆまんどゲーム漬けんだよ
いいねにタッチしたらもしるってことですね気をつけましょう
を買えるじゃんながらどういうこと
ん
怖いなぁ4
全便レジャー詰まってまったん
全米ねーじゃん
じゃあなぁ